[Musique]
ouais avec vincent tirer
julien gens cela
tiens aujourd'hui
atrium enyele et jérôme minière les
halls une journée pour tourner un sketch
improvisé handicap
un des personnages un frère jumeau au
bien placé lyon lyon fra j'appelais
c'est parce que tu savais pas qu'il
savait que je savais et moi non oui
c'est ça
[Musique]
oh
bah
il t'a vraiment dit ça ouais enfin je
crois pas non si dirais que c'est ce que
j'aurais voulu qu'ils disent tu vois toi
aussi tu même si tous les vendredis 17
heures j'ai footing six piscines est
après celui des gens ça me détend et on
verra comment ça va
ben moi j'ai carrière un peu j'avais
pourtant c'est une belle trace de sens
c'est très joli
ah non ceci n'est pas de boulot que j'ai
mangé quoi si le pouls de prologis tués
on vient mon histoire les amis si vous
comptez sortir des clés des vents je
conseille de mai couple poids léger tué
direct mais il met en confiance après
les gens s'en sortent mieux c'est pas le
but et tutu a dit quoi comme réplique
style et c'est pas un truc du genre
ta vie ne tenait qu'à moi j'ai du mal
avec les phrases d'accroché non pourquoi
attention les yeux coucou qui sait que
là ça sort du placard et pour toques upa
homosexuels les pubs et alors ça va
bonjour je viens pour le meurtre c'est
bien c'est bien mais tu sais l'essentiel
c'est la mise en scène
ou téléporte ou quoi c'est pas possible
ça mais non il ya un truc toujours un
truc j'ai un frère jumeau vaginale de
reginald
coco oui mon pote c'est comme ça que les
pros mais victime par surprise ou pas pu
venir parce que tu savais pas qu'ils
savaient tu savais quoi mais je
travaille il implique le bien joué c'est
un jeu on a une journée
tonneins 4 rien et jérôme sont toujours
pas où ils vont moi je sais un peu parce
que qu'il faut aborder tout à l'heure on
est sur le tournage du premier jam
objets à placer un lion comme si on ne
l'a pas placé pour un sketch de la faim
[Applaudissements]
commencent à essayer de s'activer
on se rend compte qu'on est vraiment en
retard en fait ouais un quart d'heure où
les punchlines héroïque pendant 50
minutes
quel suspense j'ai absolument victoire
des kings jam ja suis content et tu peux
proposer le prochain objet à placer dans
les commentaires on choisira parmi les
plus populaires le yoyo c'est déjà pris